Terence Davis on the floor
another rebound ball number nine oh
it is wow that's a little flare look at
that pass right on the money in stride
[Applause]
Paul protects leaves it for Ben oh 96.
to Miles and again nothing's happened
okay I'm gonna drive draw Kick Biz you
finish it and play above the
pull on to pulling for these teammates
here in the closing minutes James
breaker trying to work in lots of guys
as well what a pass by ball leading monk
beautifully down the Open Floor lamelo
ball
with the one-handed bounce pass on the
money to monks Charlotte's up by four
[Music]
misses his first shot full-length
baseball pass
Edward Gordon Hayward just caught it in
rhythm
it is almost like a little post-up just
turn right over to left shoulder
Splash it
[Applause]
Cody oh wonderful
mellow another flyby by connaughton that
gives lamello a straight line drive
Lopez has to step up to stop the ball
and Cody says thank you
I now get it back here comes lamelo ball
with his hair on fire
[Applause]
and he had to Windmill it to get it to
go down
the defender was there I don't think he
could have dumped it just right out all
right let's do it maybe the Sixers get a
hand on it windmilling oh
not going to change it you got to
respect that and now you see why he
doesn't want to change it oh wonderful
Heads Up played by lamelo saved it to
Biz gets it right back shoots a pass
over to Rozier and the reverse is gone
gone
look at this pass right there that's a
great angle good camera work to show a
reverse spin
[Music]
can't make the catch in traffic
lamelo what a pass fight brick is
welcome back to this past Battle of
fellow underhanded oh I mean that's
gotta be timing touch miles says I
missed that
chest pass from lamelo gets Levante in
rhythm
dragix left some meat on the bone here
we go Hornets have a chance get in there
yeah
yes
lamella found roadish year 80 feet away
and that is a good connection right
there
easy finish lamello ball
Rozier leaves it for biz
lamella wins a pass McDaniel
wonderful basketball
assistant stopped playing it look at
that they thought little Meadows would
take a shot hey that hair on it nice Up
and Under and a flip over the rim look
at that one hand
[Music]
here
good catch by yeah oh lamelo set him up
had the pedal the metal all quarters hit
the line This creativity
show it
Rivers quick First Step get out PJ takes
it from him
Hornets down four
[Applause]
and this is the other thing that's
impressive like literally everyone for
the Pacers whose played has played well
as Bridges Gets Lost in Translation
there nice fine by ball for the Finish
Warren was just a revelation for this
franchise in the bubble
last summer in Orlando Another look at
that lamelo ball pass
it was really
impressive in great hands Schroeder
feeds Williams good challenge by Plumley
that's what he brings to this year's
Club Bridges
[Applause]
runs it down
with it I know what to do look at this
pass right here left hand over the head
bosses is it too it's to zero punch it
in
[Applause]
he's a game shooter though I watch you
warm up every game
[Applause]
lamella
75 feet to Gordon Hayward you get a
rebound list everybody's sleeping how
perfect is that pass full length looks
like the Hornets have figured out that
[Music]
three trumpets
by CPI Security hello drives the
Baseline looks away and just lays it
right off to Bridges and one hand Hammer
slipping it right past the D
both two days off it's an eternity in
the NBA
lamello Taps it away from Giannis and
we've got another dunk Mason public
yeah that's a good start free throw line
probably for the first half of many
Instincts by lamelo you can't teach that
that's you either have it or you don't
tip set up basically to himself
and then the behind the back pass to
Mason who's all along with a reverse did
things start stopping on a diamond
leaving nine cents
we'll get a steal showtime in uptown
[Music]
Atlanta has the ball in a four-point
lead
[Music]
blocked Away by Bridges
go up look at this ball handling right
here behind the back
yeah
almost everybody off the dribble at some
point you have to have a lot of movement
here because these young guys
how about that pass ball over the head
no look to Bridges let's get into people
credit because they're all standing for
that pass that was outstanding
[Music]
Cody Martin nice
bridges in the middle of the floor Cody
gets lost behind the defensive on the
Baseline lamella right here always
serving the floor left hand quickly with
a spin
[Applause]
two-point game
yeah
[Music]
lamelo Montres great catch we're tied
[Applause]
a mile after a made field goal look
Kelly Olynyk just falls asleep the
entire team just falls asleep
how's Bridges all alone
Hornets leading by nine super important
game
[Applause]
that's how you do it
quickly Look Away PJ two-hand chin up
people in uptown like what they're
seeing
pretty darn good stuff
some Tyrese
nice look there for the Hornets normally
teams will short and Shrink that
rotation a little bit look at the Bell
right here what Vision to the races what
do you got
perfect steal who's with me that would
be trizz between the legs thrown off the
glass and punch in home the metal hadn't
made it three so far lamelo darts inside
extra pass look at that brilliant
basketball Nick Richards
lamelo hadn't done anything in a while
to PJ
I was down to PJ hanging all over the
rim
season High three dunks for P.J
Washington that's a tough drive for
Desmond Bayne
that's just a long range shooter
[Applause]
creatively to McDaniels
set up by the kids
the vision just the courage to take it
I'd be scared to turn that thing over
nine points next to his name one man
Wrecking Crew lamelo still in the ball
game no luck pass the nation another
assist for Alabama ball and another
punch for Mason
[Music]
[Applause]
from Duke